in the wake of representative Alon
O'Mara's repeated anti-jewish slurs and
accusations Nancy Pelosi tries to take a
vote to condemn anti-semitism how do you
think that went unfortunately for Pelosi
a generational divide has emerged among
Democrats on the question of Israel and
anti-semitism we will analyze why the
left no longer likes the Jews then a
leftist thug attacks a conservative
activist at UC Berkeley that man has now
been arrested but in a culture that
equates speech with violence will that
man ever see justice we'll find out
illegal immigration is on track to
triple 2017 levels and then finally a
billionaire dies during penis
enlargement surgery all the money in the
world we will get to that plus the
mailbag on Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
so big big news that's still breaking as
we're talking about it and we'll see
what changes maybe even during this show
you've followed representative Ilan Omar
she is this woman who has accused Israel
of hypnotizing the world who has said
that the world needs to awaken to the
evil doings of Israel she was asked why
people in America support Israel and she
said it's all about the Benjamins baby
she doesn't like Israel and she doesn't
like to Jews this much is clear she's
got a long history of extremism so now
there's this generational divide that's
broken out among Democrats the older
Democrats like Nancy Pelosi want her to
apologize and to stop criticizing Jews
unfairly stop attacking Jews and get her
to stop these comments and then there's
the younger side Alexandria cassia
Cortes Rashidah Talib who are defending
her on it now you've got Pelosi you've
got rahm emanuel just wrote an op-ed i
think in the atlantic you've got the old
guard here saying condemn this and the
new kids I don't want to defend it
Alexandria Cassio Cortes rather the new
kids don't want to condemn it
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes said that alon
omar is simply defending US foreign
policy she is now this is an anti-jewish
it's just defending or questioning
rather US foreign policy now that is not
the case where is the difference you
know I don't throw the phrase
anti-semitism around lightly I almost
never used the phrase racism I try to be
more specific because those phrases have
been emptied of meaning what
Ilana Mar is doing is anti-jewish it is
anti-semitism we will explain the
difference and we'll see how this is
going to damage Democrats in 2020 but
first let's make a little money honey
with purple match for seven on the road
now for how long for a few days it was
in New York I'm in Cincinnati tonight I
I'm a broken man because I'm so far away
from my purple mattress which I love I'm
spoiled now because this mattress that
is not a memory foam exactly it is not
an innerspring it is this new technology
developed by rocket science
it is both firm and soft at the same
time I was totally skeptical of it I
almost didn't want to take the mattress
because I was I kind of liked my old
mattress I I don't like change I'm
obviously very conservative one night I
was hooked on this thing it is the best
mattress I've ever had you should get
one you should tell your friends to get
one I tell all my friends to get one
they're fabulous you get a 100 night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund
backed by 10 year warranty there is free
in-home setup an old mattress rule free
shipping and returns you're not gonna
want to return it you are gonna love
purple right now our listeners will get
a free purple pillow with the purchase
of a mattress that is in addition to the
great free gifts they're offering
site-wide just text cough FAC OVF EF e
two eight four eight eight eight that is
the only way to get this free pillow
text offa CoV fe fe two eight four eight
eight eight c OV e f EF e 2 8 4 8 8 8
message and data rates may apply what
Alon Omar is different than simply
criticizing Israel 1 it seems like her
criticisms come unprovoked I pray and
and they're so outrageous they're not
just saying ok
the the Venezuelan dictator needs to be
ousted ok China needs to address its
trade policies ok
Russia needs to stop interfering with
our interests in the Middle East
ok it's not that it's saying there is a
particular evil of Israel and they are
in Jews in America or not trustworthy
they're not loyal to our country because
they have a dual allegiance they have a
dual loyalty
she's now said that she's expected to
have allegiance to another country
meaning Israel to work in the US
Congress that just is not true and that
is what this is where it crosses over
the line when her criticism of Israel is
so unlike normal criticism of any other
country that's how you know that it's
prompted by something else and so you've
got the old guard in the house you've
got the new guard the AOC types they're
fighting it out where is the future
the Democratic Party gonna be just look
at the 2020 candidates of the 2020
Democrat candidates they are all
universally defending alon omar so much
for the Jews they're throwing them out
the out the bus for the 2020 race Bernie
Sanders said quote we must develop an
even-handed Middle East policy which
brings Israelis and Palestinians
together for a lasting peace what I fear
is going on in the house now is an
effort to target congresswoman Omar as a
way of stifling that debate so this is
what they're all doing they're making
alon omar into the victim Alon omar is
the one praying that all awakened
people's eyes to the evils of israel
saying that we need to end our friendly
relationship with israel saying that we
need to stop having dual loyalty
targeting out american jews and saying
that they're not trustworthy but alone
omar becomes the victim in this
backwards identity politics harris
Kamala Harris says quote there is a
difference between criticism of policy
or political leaders and anti-semitism
right there is a difference and what
Ilana Moore is doing is anti-semitism
Harris then says I am concerned that the
spotlight being put on congresswoman
Omar may put her at risk at risk of what
it's just at risk she's a victim look
she's a victim she's at risk well
because what congresswoman Omar is doing
is saying that Jews are not loyal to
America and you can't trust them do you
think that puts Jews at risk when a
member of Congress says that do you
think when a member of Congress implies
that nefarious Jews are just paying off
every politician to support their
country in the Middle East that that
puts Jews at risk no no it's the Alon
Omar who's at risk she's a delicate
little flower in law no more she's
basically a little girl I mean she's 37
years old and a member of the United
States Congress but look you can't know
criticizing in LA no more no she's just
she's at risk and then elizabeth warren
liya Wafaa says quote branding criticism
of israel is automatically anti-semitic
will have a chilling effect on our
public discourse and makes it harder to
achieve a peaceful solution
between Israelis and Palestinians
Palestinian I think Palestine is we've
covered it a little bit before on this
show it's the country between Narnia and
Wakanda it's I think it's to the east of
Narnia and to the west of Wakanda so
that's what Elizabeth Warren is talking
about here now of course she's right
yeah of course you can't brand any
criticism of Israel as anti-semitism but
that's not what we're doing we're using
very specific examples and the left
won't acknowledge those examples why
congrat until right now congressional
Democrats would not vote for a
resolution to condemn anti-semitism even
one that didn't mention Ilan Omar by
name now I'm just getting in that they
are going to vote on a they are going to
vote on a resolution to condemn hatred
but not specifically and exclusively
anti-semitism they're going to vote on
something to condemn all forms of
bigotry and this is one of the great
ironies of recent politics do you
remember a year ago two years ago you
had the black lives matter movement and
that Capanna its will be as they say do
black lives matter and you know what
they would say they say all lives matter
they'd say how dare you
oh the left was outraged by all lives
matter because all lives matter
undermines and overshadows the the
specific in particular fact that black
lives matter how dare you generalize
when we are condemning a specific form
of bigotry unless it's against the Jews
and then it's great and then that's what
we have to do pure hypocrisy from the
left now this is all just taking the
premises of leftist identity politics as
they are just pointing out the internal
inconsistencies here now the left comes
back and they say well we'll listen you
have your own racial issues on the right
sure I guess so I guess every the man's
heart is evil from the very beginning so
yeah sure okay I guess we're falling
people there are they're gonna be bigots
all over the place they're saying well
you have Steve King
member Republican representative Steve
King he asked the question he said white
supremacy white nationalism Western
civilization when did that become
controversial and what Steve King said
is I was taken out of context I meant to
say I was listing these things and then
White's Western civilization is what I
was asking when it became controversial
akat and off that totally carries water
but then what happened when he got
called out for it Steve King went on the
floor of the house do we have the clip
today the New York Times is suggesting
that I am an advocate for white
nationalism and white supremacy I want
to make one thing abundantly clear I
reject those labels and the evil
ideology that they define further I
condemn anyone that supports this evil
and bigoted ideology which saw in its
ultimate expression this is the
systematic murder of six million
innocent Jewish lives it's true that
like the founding fathers I am an
advocate for Western civilization's
values and that i profoundly believe
that America is the greatest tangible
expression of these ideals the world has
ever seen under any fair political
definition I am simply an American
nationalist could not be clearer he
whatever he said in that interview with
The New York Times whether he was
misquoted whether he was quoted
perfectly he comes out there he says I
reject this evil ideology I condemn
anybody who supports this evil ideology
they then had a vote based on the
quotation that the New York Times
reported from him they had this
resolution to condemn white supremacy
and it was seen largely as a rebuke to
Steve King what did Steve King do he
voted for his own rebuke what more can
the man do how about on the right though
what has he lawn home are done she said
oh I'm sorry
wink oh I'm gonna I'm so I didn't mean
to say that wink
tee-hee-hee and then what does she do
she keeps it up she keeps up the dual
loyalty smears the can't trust a juice
mirrors she keeps it all up and what
happens what happened to any Republican
who defended Steve Cain on the merits of
that quote that he was reported to have
said what would happen they would be
they would be ostracized from America
Society there be thrown out of the
country and yet you have fresh-faced
popular Democrat members of Congress
defending Olano more on this what's very
interesting about this with this is
something nobody is talking about it is
actually the most interesting aspect of
this whole alon omar anti-semitism
debate is the difference between right
wing and left wing anti-semitism and how
alon omar is actually engaging in right
wing anti-semitism her defenders are
engaging in left-wing will discuss the
difference but first we have a new
sponsor to talk about you have got to
check this out
it is the podcast hostage this is from
the park ass network behind every
hostage situation there is a complex
dynamic between the hostage and the
captor and the negotiator say the wrong
thing you make a wrong move that
hostages life could be in jeopardy could
be on your hands
every Thursday forecast networks podcast
hostage tells the complicated stories
behind the world's most intense hostage
situations and the people inside them
hostage explores the psychological
tactics used in hostage negotiations and
what the human brain does when a person
is held captive find out how hostage
situations transpire what strategies
negotiators employ to find a peaceful
resolution hostage highlights the
moments where things went tragically
wrong as well as the techniques that
have miraculously saved lives and you
should definitely check out the two-part
episode on captain Phillips of the MV
Maersk Alabama you remember captain
Phillips they made a whole movie about
it and you remember how it ends I don't
want to spoil it for you but it ends in
a very cool way check out how it all
began with the thrilling three-part
episode on the Hearst kidnapping search
for and subscribe to hostage where ever
you listen to podcasts you know I don't
do a Friday show
check it out on Friday I love I'm always
looking for podcasts I consume a ton of
podcasts and I love hostage you should
check it out don't forget to rate it and
review it so the most interesting aspect
of this whole omars
debacle on anti-semitism is the one that
nobody's talking about which is the
difference between right-wing
anti-semitism in the left-wing
anti-semitism look today anti-semitism
appears to be for the very large part a
left-wing problem
that wasn't always the case when the
right is anti-semitic in history when
the right has been anti-semitic has not
liked the Jews has excluded the Jews the
line of attack usually goes something
like this
the Jews are seen as rootless
Cosmopolitan's with no allegiance with
no loyalty to the countries that they
live in and they control the world
usually through finance or debt
specifically and this financial power
combined with higher levels of education
also allows them to control the media
more or less that is the kind of
traditional anti-semitic narrative that
has been embraced at times by some
groups on the right Elano more leftist
Democrat politician has centered her
criticism specifically as it relates to
Israel and to her Arab neighbors using
this line of attack this is the line of
attacks she's using all about the
Benjamins baby dual loyalty allegiance
to another country you can't trust them
when it comes to this country she is
using the classic traditional
anti-semitic narrative but the people
who are defending alon omar are not
using that traditional narrative they
are actually defending Elana mores
anti-semitism from the left-wing
anti-semitic point of view and that
leftist angle is basically this it's it
uses parts of the traditional angle but
it views it through an intersectional
identity politics scope which is you
would think the normal person would say
okay identity politics intersectionality
you're all about protecting oppressed
minorities the Jews have been oppressed
for a very long time they were slaves in
Egypt people try to kill them every 50
years or so clearly if if anyone's got a
grudge to bear it would be the Jews and
the leftist angle on it is this the Jews
are not really a persecuted ethnic and
religious minority because the Jews are
successful so you can say this uses the
kind of classic line which is the Jews
are successful in finance the Jews are
successful in the media the Jews are
successful in the arts and because
they are successful in those fields
fields that they've traditionally been
permitted into because they've been
successful they lose their victims
status so victimhood has currency in
2019 in the leftist intersectional
ideology they lose that currency of
victimhood because of their success
because for the left success is a sin
success not just when we're speaking
about racial or religious demographics
success broadly is a sign that you have
cheated it's a sign that you weren't
playing fair the old-line the only way
that the fat guy got fat was by stealing
the food of the skinny guy the only way
the rich guy got rich was stealing the
money of the poor guy that's the leftist
idea the static world where it's all
just competing interests nobody can work
together no rising tide can lift all
ships so the fact that the Jews as if
people have succeeded the fact that
Israel specifically is a thriving
democracy surrounded by absolute rubble
in that region that is prima facie
evidence that the Jews and Israel have
cheated and they've oppressed people
that's how the Left views it it is
evidence therefore that they can't be
protected as are other oppressed
minorities in their ideology the Jews
according to the left have basically
become indistinguishable from the wasp
culture the white anglo-saxon
Protestants whatever particular version
of white that you identify as the man as
the dominant racial or cultural group
the Jews are now considered white
according to the left and so this group
obviously a small religious and ethnic
minority as far as the world population
goes and as far as the American
population goes becomes big-daddy they
become the top of the pyramid they lose
their victim status and so it is okay to
attack them and to attack their country
in Israel even if the two arguments
don't necessarily coincide and it's
amazing to see Ilan Omar at the center
of this she's the one uniting them she's
the one using that classic line of
attack and being defended by a totally
different line of attack
and it's going to keep up eventually
when every LAN Omar why's this Wise's up
a little bit she'll drop the kind of
classic anti-semitic slurs because by
the way if she just hadn't used that old
narrative she would have gotten away
with it she hadn't gone through these
old tropes that the left has rejected
and she'd used the new leftist
anti-semitic narrative she would have
completely gotten away with a lot of
people on the Left have done that for
years they've the left is basically
permitted boycott divestment sanction is
basically attacked Israel for years and
years and years they've done it in a
more subtle way in a more modern way
Alon Omar is showing showing us
anti-semitism through the ages how it
morphs and the the freshman Democrats
are leading that into the future and the
2020 Democrat candidates for president
have adopted it
now speaking of leftist victimizers do
you remember this happened a little
while ago conservative activists took a
punch from a leftist activist on the UC
Berkeley campus this was a caught on
tape I think we have the tape of it oh
so this guy is there this this
conservative guy Hayden Williams
he is helping students organize a
conservative chapter on campus and they
have a sign that it says hate hoaxes
hurt real victims that that's in regard
to the Jesse Smollett hoax race and hate
hoax he makes us perfectly obvious point
that hate hoaxes hurt real victims duh
and this leftist lunatic goes up and
punches right in the face now it turns
out that guy's been arrested his name is
Zachary greenberg turns out he's got a
long rap sheet assaults restraining
orders obviously the guy's a thug and
it's no surprise that he's got a rap
sheet but that guy is an example of a
broader problem on the left this is not
the first time we've seen this we saw
this two years ago at Berkeley there was
a Danna Community College
professor by the name of Eric Clanton
it's easy to remember because it sounds
like Eric Clapton so I'm picturing Eric
Clapton you know attacking conservatives
with tire irons but no it was not
Clapton it was Eric Clanton a community
college professor himself and he
attacked conservatives hit them on the
head with a bike lock so this happened
two years ago what happens what was he
sentenced to what's the justice nothing
they've got three years probation
doesn't have to go to jail doesn't have
to pay any fines nope
three years probation he's all good this
is a scary trend this is part of a
broader trend and it's evidence that a
culture that defines speech as violence
is not going to punish people when they
react violently to simple speech this is
what the left is done but the buckley
program at yale took a survey showed
that eighty-one percent of college
students say that some forms of speech
are violence not that they incite
violence not that they depict violence
that they are violence
now if speech is violence then when
someone says something you don't like
you are justified in attacking that
person so attack some conservatives were
minding their own business expressing
their opinion are now justified because
it was the first this the conservative
speaker was violent first violent with
his words and so I was violent with a
tire iron since his violence
self-defense really so much for sticks
and stones can break my bones words will
never hurt me but my tire iron will hurt
you this is what happens if President
Trump talked about this at CPAC he made
a brilliant point on it he took a hard
punch in the face for all of us remember
that he took the punch for all of
I'm glad he brought it up and he's right
he did he he took a punch for all of us
because the left wasn't just going after
Hayden Williams this guy was going after
all of us all of us with whom he
disagrees and he thinks he can punch us
all in the face because he disagrees
with what we're saying this is very
important for Trump to make an issue of
this he was criticized in some corners
for making an issue out of this
scrap at scrapple at Berkeley but this
is the issue this is why I did that
Prager video control the words control
the culture this is why the war on
political correctness is so important
this is why it's important that we use
correct pronouns not the fantasy
pronouns that the left is bizarrely
insisting on but real language because
the left is willing to take a swing at
you they're willing to hit you with a
bike lock if you don't use their
fictitious words because words matter
because this obviously matters and we
can't let them get away with it
and it's perfectly right for the
President of the United States to get up
there and say he took a punch for all of
us they're trying to swing at all of us
we have to fight this tooth and nail
that's the issue
and if eighty-one percent of college
students think that speech is violence
we need to make it clear to them if it's
not we need to teach them where their
parents and their teachers have failed
words and why are not violence they're
very different things we'll see what
happens I'm speaking on a college campus
tonight maybe someone's gonna show up
with a bike lock there I hope not I hope
the Cincinnati kids are a lot better
educated than the kids at UC Berkeley we
also have got to get to the immigration
debate I was at yesterday I was on the
Fox show outnumbered it was me and four
ladies on a couch was you know not a bad
show to be on I usually am in my broom
closet all day long all by myself and
it's a sprain if it's burning that's
nice to be around people is what I'm
saying and we had this debate on illegal
immigration and to my left Jessica
Tarlov who I like very much she's the
liberal on the panel she said I would
say you know it's not come on it's not
it's not a national emergency come on
come on this is a crisis this is a
crisis the people coming across our
border so we know we've reached an 11
year high in
you arey 76,000 illegal aliens came into
our country this is way way up over 2500
people a day and they're expecting
higher numbers as the weather warms up
the DHS secretary Kirsten Nielsen
testified about this yesterday our
capacity is already severely restrained
but these increases will overwhelm the
system entirely this is not a
manufactured crisis this is truly an
emergency it's an emergency
now why why is this happening now
because it at the start of Trump's
presidency illegal immigration was at a
low and then it sort of ticked back up
why part of this is because President
Trump has facilitated a booming economy
the economy wasn't fabulous when he took
office it's done a whole lot better so
you have a lot of economic migrants who
want to come over here and get good jobs
the other reason is Donald Trump made
his presidential campaign totally
focused on stopping illegal immigration
and the people who were crossing our
borders illegally were dumb enough to
think that we were serious about it they
thought I mean they're not dumb they may
be they gave us the benefit of the doubt
they thought we were being honest but no
this country we've learned is not able
to defend its own borders and so when
they learned that very quickly President
Trump couldn't stop illegal immigration
they all started coming again now the
left one stabbed at both ways here they
want to have children and their families
United as they're being processed but
then as we learned from the Flores
Agreement 1997 during the Clinton
administration you can't have the
parents and the children in the same
place because the parents are being
processed by law enforcement there
aren't that many places where you can
house them together and you can't have a
child in jail for very long so you've
got to have the child process by Health
and Human Services but you've got the
parents who broke the law they're adults
you can't just let them off the hook for
breaking the law which is the only other
option that the Democrats have left us
open borders let them go that's how they
enforce border security they don't they
don't enforce the law all of this is to
say we now have 15 GOP senators who are
gonna vote against this emergency
declaration by the president we have 31
now 32
national emergencies currently on the
books most of them really aren't
national emergencies this one is a
national emergency and even if you say
well okay it's 11-year high seventy six
thousand illegal aliens invading our
country in just one month but hey come
on this has been going on for a long
time right that's right this is how Dru
often quotes Hemingway and how people go
bankrupt and the Sun Also Rises guy says
how did you go bankrupt he says
gradually then suddenly that's if you
have a moderate crisis for forty years
that becomes a big crisis becomes a
national emergency gradually then
suddenly this is not the time for GOP
senators to go weak are we to say that
only Democrat presidents are allowed to
declare national emergencies well they
say the Democrats once they have this
power might use it on something else
right the Democrats already have this
power well okay but but it's the
national emergency act is wrong in the
first place okay fine then repeal the
national emergency act but don't prevent
President Trump from using it for a
legitimate emergency well where's he
gonna get the money the national
emergency act specifically talks about
military construction maybe that's why
he invoked it now is not the time to go
weak this is a major issue and just
because it was a major issue yesterday
and a major issue the day before doesn't
mean that it isn't an even bigger issue
today just because the the Frog is in
the pot and the water is getting hotter
by one degree every day doesn't mean
that eventually that frog isn't going to
boil they should not go weak on this I
have another story that I really wanted
to get to today about a huge Rea Lonnie
Otto a billionaire who died during penis
enlargement surgery at the age of 65 I
really wanted to get to this story this
story tells us a lot about our culture
but we just don't have time to do it
because we have to get to the mailbag so
I guess that's a reason to come back
tomorrow we will have a Friday show
tomorrow because we were unable to do
one yesterday tonight I'm gonna be at
the University of Cincinnati we are
going to be talking about global warming
and the green
New Deal and why it's a leftist cult and
why it won't do anything to help the
earth and why the people who push it
don't even really care about helping the
earth we'll talk about all of that
tonight at the University of Cincinnati
I think you can tune in on either
Yaffe's livestream or daily wires one of
us is going to be putting out so check
all of our social media pages we will
have links for you there in the meantime
before we get to the mailbag go to daily
wire comm ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
Andrew Klavan show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag you get the Matt Walsh oh
you get another Kingdom you get to ask
questions but you get so much you get
the leftist ears tumblr you get it this
is very important as it is revealed for
the next two weeks that the Democrats
can't even hold a vote to condemn
jew-hatred
as there is a major fissure in the
Democrat Party as Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez eats Nancy Pelosi for breakfast
you're gonna need that tumbler there
gonna be a lot of Tears there's gonna be
a lot of wailing as the 2020 Democrat
candidates jump over themselves one
after another to say that Jew hatred
isn't Jew hatred oh it's going to be as
chaton for in a field event to make sure
that you have your tumbler go to daily
wire calm we'll be back with a lot more
first question in the mailbag from Jason
Michael can we abort aoc the logic here
being of course if you're going to board
a kid at the 3rd trimester
then you can probably aboard a kid after
he's born like Ralph Northam says like
the national Democrats say so you can
probably aboard a kid at 29 like
Alexandria cassio Cortes well by the
logic of the left by the logic of
abortion we certainly can abort
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes as long as her
mother and doctor talk about it however
I think it would be very bad to abort
okay ah CEO Cortez I really enjoy her on
the national political scene I think she
is making political issues very clear so
often in the old days in the days of the
Clintons they would obscure their real
motives they would say oh listen
abortion it should be safe legal and
rare that doesn't make any sense if it's
tantamount to murder why should it be
legal if it's not tantamount to murder
why should it be rare what it doesn't
make any sense
now what alexandria or cassia Cortes
says is no no
here is the logical conclusion here's
the radical conclusion of all of these
ideas all of this ideology you would
hear the global warming types the people
who the left basically just wants to use
the idea of global warming to take all
of the power that they've wanted for a
hundred years and to push socialism in
through the backdoor and so you'd say
well if the world is going to end in ten
years if this is really threatening life
on Earth as we know it one you need to
produce evidence of that and two if
that's true we need to totally upend all
of human society to save ourselves no
say no no we just just give us a little
more power yeah just give us a little
more tax taxes yeah that no no don't
worry I mean yeah the world's gonna end
it's no it's gonna end in 12 years so
give us your money give us more of your
power
give us your liberty and your political
freedoms but nobody said no it's okay
though it's no no don't ask too many
questions
and she takes it to the logical
conclusion she says no no it's going to
end in 12 years we need to destroy every
building in the country and
that we need to outlaw 88% of American
energy we need to outlook house we need
outlaw airplanes yeah no we have to it's
the logical conclusion I'm very happy
that a OC is following these ideas to
the illogical conclusion I want to give
her more airtime that's why I talk about
her a lot that's why I analyze what
she's saying a lot and also to her
credit well Democrats are just talking
about how Donald Trump you know didn't
tip his waiter in 1983 and that's the
most progressive thing they can talk
about Alexandria Ocasio Cortes it has
the political courage to offer ideas
they're crazy ideas their perverse ideas
but at least she's offering them so that
we can debate them I would never want to
debate AOC some people who like abortion
they say well we should listen the
people who are being aborted their
welfare people they're stupid people
they're no we don't we don't want their
undesirables such as Margaret Sanger
would write about in woman in the new
race the founder of Planned Parenthood
that doesn't hold water even if I didn't
like what Alexandria cassio Cortez is
doing in the political media so much
even if I didn't like that even if I
thought you were the worst person in the
world I still don't think she should be
aborted because it is wrong to kill
innocent little babies it's the way it
is but good question I mean listen this
is a confused culture if you took the
left at its word totally you should be
able to do it from James what's your
opinion on the convention of states the
convention of states is the idea that
states are all gonna get together and
they're going to amend the Constitution
because we can't do it through Congress
and we're gonna make certain things
clear around it's gonna be great for
American freedom I don't like it I think
it's a terrible idea I don't want these
people who are alive today to rewrite
our constitution some people say oh
don't worry it won't be a big deal it
will be very limited we don't know that
it's never happened before things can
get out of control very quickly the
point of a constitution is to tie us we
the living to our forebears and to our
future it's the greatest democracy of
all as Chesterton would say it's the
democracy of the Dead it ensures this
survival of a certain sense of American
tradition I don't want to touch that at
all I don't want to get near that with a
ten-foot pole no thank you
there are it is true there is a much
better world that we could imagine a
much better government than we could
imagine than the one that we currently
have which has been so perverted since
the time of the founding I don't think
that we are likely to succeed in shaping
that government in fact I think the left
has their own version of a far better
government with far less political
Liberty for you and me far more control
for the collective federal government
and I I don't want to give them the
opportunity to explore that dream I
think it's a bad idea a lot of good
people smart people are taking that idea
on they think it's they're really gung
ho for it I think that the road to hell
is paved with good intentions and we
should stay away from it from Cesar hi
Michael you're my favorite commentator
on The Daily wire oh thank you very much
thanks do you hear that fellas did you
are you watching and listening now do
you think FDR's New Deal
aka government intervention was
necessary to stabilize the American
financial system
I'm always questioned and presented the
New Deal as a good example of government
takeover I look forward to your
viewpoint no absolutely not it was a
terrible disastrous program for the
American economy it delayed recoveries
significantly we were only able to
recover when the whole rest of the world
blew itself up and we were the dominant
superpower
it was awful I mean you had the Franklin
Roosevelt setting the price of gold
based on lucky numbers that's no joke
you can read about this it was horrific
wage could price controls all of these
awful things actually those programs
gave us are totally convoluted American
healthcare system all the problems with
American health care basically date back
to those wage controls because when you
try to suppress people's creativity and
enterprise it doesn't work it's gonna
find expression somewhere else so the
government said we need wage controls
this was this was ultimately during
World War two this is slightly after the
New Deal has been implemented but
they've got all of these wage controls
because they have a labor shortage and
they don't want wages to shoot through
the roof
wage controls but then the the employers
need to attract talent anyway so they
start offering medical insurance and
then employer based medical insurance
has played a significant role in some of
the complexities and unnecessary
complexities in our current health care
system bad idea for the economy however
and this is where Ben and I differ a
little bit probably while it was not
economically necessary it was
politically necessary you had riots in
the streets you had a lot of people who
one had a lot more progressive plans
radical plans for the government and
unfortunately sometimes you need to
violate economic reality to deal with
political reality because that's what
government does deals in politics the
affairs of men and so I give FDR a
little bit of leeway because he was
dealing in political reality Ronald
Reagan hated tariffs wanted free trade
ostensibly during his presidency but he
instituted those steel tariffs why
because sometimes you need to protect
American industry because you're a
politician you just got to do it next
question from Andrew hello Michael I
personally believe that God views all
sin equally due to the fact that all
things being equal any man can be driven
to commit any sin entirely due to the
circumstances that his soul has been
placed in when they can went why then
can some sin as scripture says not be
mortal thank you Andrew Andrew what you
are falling into is the error of
fatalism bordering on heresy if not full
heresy this error of fatalism has been
present from man icky ISM at the time of
st. Agustin all the way up through the
present day this is the idea that all
events are determined by fate and free
will plays no role this is wrong this is
not true this is not Christian you do
have free will there is Providence there
is omnipotence there is omniscience and
you have free will your will does play a
role it is not totally fatalistically
determined that you will commit some sin
you have moral culpability here your
will has a role and so this I hope that
helps to explain your problem
that part of Scripture which it clearly
shows that all sin is not equal in the
eyes of God from grant dear Michael from
dear Michael from the block like Jenny
what is your opinion on a poli-sci
degree many people seem to think it's
useless yes Ben
who has a poli-sci degree says that it's
useless and I agree
basically that's true political
philosophy is very good if you can find
a program that focuses on political
philosophy then I think that's quite
worthwhile if the program is just
political science trying to teach people
to treat people as predictable robots
and automate Ahn's just focusing on
statistics or something that's probably
useless this is because there are lies
damned lies and statistics this is
because the social sciences can be
highly politicized and turned into just
a biology class and because if you use a
traditional academic discipline like
history or philosophy or I suppose you I
mean look literature is actually a good
way to learn about politics there are a
lot of ways in the traditional liberal
arts to learn about politics that are
probably better than poli-sci from
Nicole hi Michael my friends main
argument for voting democrat is climate
change and they appreciate that
Democrats make more of an effort to
address it they argue at least Democrats
are trying
is it better to not propose any ideas to
address environmental issues or to only
suggest bad ones
well we actually got to this a little
bit earlier in the show the Democrats
are being disingenuous they're saying
well the world is all gonna end but just
give it just a little bit more power
that's okay it's basically a way of a
laying guilt it functions as a religion
so I think it's totally disingenuous but
why they make an effort I mean the road
to hell is paved with good intentions if
they're destroying her economy and
destroying our political liberties in a
way that's totally ineffective what good
are they doing it's just virtues
signaling it's totally empty oh ask your
ask your friends what good is being
accomplished see if they can answer from
more cell
Ave Michael I recently met a
non-denominational Christian and asked
her what she would give up for Lent she
said she does not practice land because
who cares about pointless old traditions
and why should we follow them wasn't
sure how to respond love - oh thanks one
way to respond is to ask her how she's
so confident that the traditions are
pointless
by definition traditions are old by
definition they're also new because
they've survived for at so much time
there's there's obviously some vital
force within the tradition by definition
how does she know they're pointless can
she describe what the tradition is can
she explain why it was instituted in the
first place couldn't you explain why
people have done it over time this to me
is the height of intellectual arrogance
and it's very shallow its Chesterton's
fence when you see the fence in the
middle of the road you have no idea why
it's there don't just rip it down first
you've got to figure out why it was
there in the first place and then only
then can you possibly be ready to tear
down that tradition and I wonder does
she not engage in any old traditions I
bet she's a non-denominational Christian
probably goes to church on Sunday why
does she engage in that pointless old
tradition was a point is it not
pointless why is it a tradition why does
she do that maybe ask her about some of
the old tradition she does - this
tradition is very important we we have
bodies we are people we have ritual we
have need of sacrament we have need to
encounter the metaphysical in the
physical world last question from James
hey Michael I've identified as an
atheist for the past 10 years which I'm
beginning to regret I'm struggling to
get back into religion do you have any
suggestions to help me yes trick the
devil by appealing to intellectual pride
this is what I did this is I think a
cause of atheism a lot in the culture
today and one way to get past it is to
realize that the arguments for atheism
are extremely stupid the devil is he
always seemed so convincing and
persuasive and then you realize he's a
fool he's a Saint John Vianney would
make fun of him called him little idiot
do that maybe appeal in that way try to
work around that way I mean you know
listen you're asking me the question you
so you clearly value my opinion I'm
telling you God exists the smartest
people in all of history or telling you
that God exists so figure out why that
is how that is how you've come to not
believe all right I'm doing one more I
don't care if we're gonna run late from
Michael it's cuz you have a great name
hi Michael no one has really clearly
articulated the difference between
socialism and communism what is the
difference between the two I'll explain
it between the three I'll include Nazism
in there too
socialism is an economic and political
philosophy where by the means of
production whereby property is generally
owned by the collective by the
government you see this as socialists in
Congress call for 80% rates of Taxation
and wealth taxes and so you're just
taking property as bits just theft now
there are different kinds there's
democratic socialism that's what we see
with occasion treat as there is
international socialism that's what
communism is soviet communism was an
international movement workers of the
world unite so wasn't focusing
specifically and primarily on race or
sex or it within the country it's
focusing internationally get all of the
labor of the world to unite then we'll
have an international socialist
federation and then there is national
socialism which is Nazism which has a
much more national focus to it but as an
economic philosophy or a political
system they all broadly share socialism
and so sometimes people will say well
so-and-so is a democratic socialist not
a National Socialist you're not an
internationals okay whatever fine
socialist nonetheless same thing okay
that's our show
we're running too late check out the
speech tonight at University of
Cincinnati should be a lot of fun and
then I'll see you tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Doyle show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19